[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg
guten abend schön dass sie dabei sind
wie auch norbert lehmann für den sprach
und
das sind die wichtigsten themen von
heute
mahnung am holocaust-gedenktag
überlebende erinnern an die gräueltaten
der nazis und warnen vor einem neuen
alltäglichen judenhass
200.000 neue fälle an einem tag die
korona zahlen in deutschland steigen
weiter eine trendwende ist nicht in
sicht und
beurteilt zur anonymität im internet
facebook muss nutzern in bestimmten
fällen ermöglichen ihre echten namen zu
verbergen
viele menschen wissen erschreckend wenig
über den holocaust es hat gerade wieder
eine neue studie bestätigt umso
wichtiger sind tage wie diese 27 januar
an dem weltweit der millionen opfer des
nationalsozialismus gedacht wird der tag
erinnert an die befreiung des
konzentrationslagers auschwitz
1945 durch die rote armee bei der
gedenkstunde im bundestag sagte
parlamentspräsidentin bärbel bas der
antisemitismus ist mitten unter uns zur
wachsamkeit riefen auch zwei frauen auf
die den holocaust überlebt haben inge
auerbacher in berlin und margot
friedländer im europaparlament in
brüssel anne gellinek und andreas
huppert berichten
sie ist dem holocaust entkommen hat
hunger krankheiten und die
unmenschlichkeit der nazis in
konzentrationslager
überlebte war das mädchen mit der puppe
vor 87 jahren in südbaden geboren
erzählt den abgeordneten von dem tag
1942 als sie mit ihrer familie unter der
transport nummer 4 08 ins kz
theresienstadt
deportiert wird ich war sieben jahre alt
und die jüngste von circa 1100 personen
von denen meine eltern und ich und ganz
wenig andere überlebt haben denn hass
auf juden bekommt sie am eigenen leibe
zu spüren kann ihn nie mehr vergessen
ihre politische botschaft lautet deshalb
judenhass ist in vielen ländern der welt
auch in deutschland wieder alltäglich
diese krankheit muss so schnell wie
möglich
gehalten emma bacher überlebte die nazi
gräuel millionen andere überleben nicht
vom holocaust als historische trauma
spricht mit levy präsident des
israelischen parlaments aber auch von
den brücken die die nachfolgenden
generationen von israelis und deutschen
gebaut hätten deshalb müsse allen klar
sein nie wieder nie wieder
zu ehren aller opfer rezitiert levy am
ende seiner rede aus dem badisch dem
jüdischen toten gebet und kann dabei die
tränen nicht mehr zurück kann ein
hochemotionales gedenken an die opfer
des nationalsozialismus im berliner
reichstagsgebäude
es ist ungewöhnlich still im brüsseler
europaparlament als die 100 jährige
margot friedländer zu den abgeordneten
spricht sie hat das kz theresienstadt
trotz hunger und zwangsarbeit überlebt
und beschreibt jene denen es noch
schlechter ging häftlinge die aus dem
lager auschwitz zu ihnen stießen
etwas viel mehr arme ein mensch so
schwach dass ich ihn tragen muss
federleicht margot friedländer ist jüdin
1921 in berlin geboren sie träumt davon
modezeichnerin zu werden bis 1943 ihr
jüngerer bruder und ihre mutter
verhaftet und ermordet werden sie selbst
taucht in berlin unter wird doch
entdeckt und deportiert nach der
befreiung immigriert sie mit ihrem mann
in die usa versucht das erlebte zu
verdrängen bis sie 2010 nach berlin
zurückkehrt um genau darüber zu sprechen
sie sorgt sich dass die erinnerung müsse
braucht wird zb von corona leugnern
ungläubig muss sich mit meinen nunmehr
100 jahren sehen die symbole zu unserer
ausgrenzung durch die nazis der
sogenannte juden stecken
schamlos benutzt werden um sich selbst
mitten in einer demokratie als opfer zu
stilisieren
wir überlebenden sind nicht mehr lange
da sagt friedländer deshalb müsst ihr
jetzt zeitzeugen werden stehen der
applaus im europaparlament
ein bewegender tag in brüssel und berlin
wenn sie die ganze rede von inge
auerbacher hören und sehen möchten die
sie bei der gedenkstunde im bundestag
gehalten hat dann können sie das tun auf
zdf heute oder in der heute app
genau vor zwei jahren gab es den ersten
corona fall in deutschland damals ahnte
wohl kaum jemand was diese pandemie uns
abverlangen würde 24 monate und fünf
wellen später treibt aktuell die omikron
variante die zahlen zu immer neuen
höchstwerten heute haben die täglichen
neuinfektionen erstmals die
200.000 überschritten die inzidenz stieg
zum ersten mal über 1000 das bedeutet
rein rechnerisch in einer woche
infiziert sich jeder hundertste die
tatsächlichen zahlen dürften aber
deutlich höher liegen maike fahrrad
bioland
das gesundheitsamt raptor köpenick in
berlin ein corona hotspot deutschlands
hier hat sich seit beginn der pandemie
vor zwei jahren einiges geändert dass
corinna team wurde mehr als verdoppelt
und statt auf kontakt verfolgung jedes
einzelnen falls setzt man nun auf
erreichbarkeit und betreuung von
risikogruppen neue fälle kommen rein wie
am fließband die daten müssten sofort
bearbeitet und gemeldet werden
eigentlich gesagt
wir versuchen unser bestes tag für tag
fall für fall aber
das ist einfach von einem masse handy zu
schaffen berlinweit liegt der rückstand
bei fast 30.000 und so geht es vielen
gesundheitsämtern von hohen
dunkelziffern ist auszugehen
die validität der daten wird jetzt mit
der weiteren pandemiewelle wirklich
deutlich nachlassen weil wir einfach an
die belastungsgrenze der zum eine
gesundheitscenter kommen zum anderen
aber auch einfach die labore nicht mehr
hinterherkommen mit ihm messen die
zahlen sind nur bedingt mit denen aus
vorigen wellen vergleichbar denn dank
vieler impfungen und der omicron
mutation gibt es auch weniger schwere
verläufe die kliniken haben ein anderes
problem
200.000 neue infektionen heute und
nächste woche vielleicht sogar 400.000
werden die kritische infrastruktur in
deutschland doch auch eine ganz schöne
stress probe stellen und wir sehen jetzt
schon zu nehmende personalausfälle in
den kliniken
krankenhäusern mit wachsenden sorgen die
infektionszahlen nur noch ungefähr
verfügbar deutschland kämpft mit der
mikrowelle
auch in großbritannien sind die zahlen
weiterhin sehr hoch trotzdem schafft
england fast alle corona maßnahmen ab ab
heute dürfen die masken fallen auch in
geschlossenen räumen bussen und bahnen
ausnahme ist london dort geld im
öffentlichen nahverkehr weiterhin masken
pflicht in clubs und bei
großveranstaltungen sind im pfund test
nachweise nicht mehr vorgeschrieben
zum ukraine konflikt russland hat kühl
auf das schreiben der usa und der nato
reagiert mit dem die allianz gestern auf
russische forderungen geantwortet hat es
gebe keine positive reaktion auf das
hauptthema sagte außenminister lavrov
russland hatte unter anderem ein ende
der nato osterweiterung
gefordert ernsthafte gespräche seien
trotzdem möglich so lavrov aber über
zweitrangige fragen jetzt müsse
präsident putin über das weitere
vorgehen entscheiden und wie reagiert
die bundesregierung auf den aufmarsch
russischer truppen an der grenze zurück
im ausland wird die haltung deutschlands
sehr genau beobachtet die ukraine
erwartet viel mehr unterstützung aus
deutschland im bundestag versuchte die
aussenministerin heute ihren weg zu
verteidigen wenn die häscher
die debatte beobachtet auch der
ukrainische botschafter in berlin andrej
melik er hatte gestern die lieferung von
5.000 militär helm in deutschlands an
die ukraine als symbol geste bezeichnet
waffenlieferungen gefordert dazu sagt
die aussenministerin weiter nein sie
hofft auf dialog ob da was bei rauskommt
wir wissen es nicht niemand kann das in
dieser zeit
hundertprozentig sagen aber wer redet
der schießlich daher ist es fatal die
wiederaufnahme von dialog jetzt einfach
so abzutun annalena baerbock hält
sanktionen bei nordstream 2 für möglich
wie auch olaf scholz dem bundeskanzler
wird friedrich merz eine unklare
position vor sie führen nicht weder in
deutschland
märz erhält selbst contra aus der spd
für seine absage an finanzsanktionen im
zusammenhang mit dem internationalen
zahlungssystem swift ich meine es war
nicht der vorsitzende der fdp oder die
vorsitzenden der grünen oder der spd die
als erstes gerufen haben mir aber es
wirft neben wir raus das war ein sieg
sie haben der russischen seite gezeigt
dass wir dort wackeln an dieser stelle
ich habe um im bild zu bleiben was ich
gewählt habe auf die sprengkraft
hingewiesen die eine aussetzung von
swift bedeuten würde aber es liegt auch
für mich ausdrücklich mit auf dem tisch
der möglichkeiten märz schließt auch
anders als csu-chef söder
waffenlieferungen nicht mehr
ausdrücklich aus ein einheitliches bild
vermittelt sich nach außen nicht
der theo koll in berlin die wird die
ukraine politik deutschlands im ausland
wahrgenommen
nun will man in die internationalen
zeitungen schaut und finden sich dafür
die deutsche ukraine und russland
politik beschreibungen wie schwächstes
glied in der kette zickzackkurs oder
auch bremse insgesamt schauen viele
verbündete mit zunehmendem befremden auf
die deutsche außenpolitik die historisch
bedingte zurückhaltung wird zwar oft
noch anerkannt aber mit abnehmender
überzeugungskraft führende us-militärs
fragen beispielsweise wie so könnt ihr
jede menge waffen nach ägypten liefern
aber nicht in die ukraine
der amerikanische präsident biden hält
sich mit direkter kritik zurück aber um
ihn herum scheint die geduld mit der
deutschen außenpolitik abzunehmen
befremdet sind vor allem viele
osteuropäer dass die bundesregierung
beispielsweise eastern noch daran
hindert haubitzen aus ddr beständen in
die ukraine zu liefern das sei so sagen
kritiker eine schande und die zugesagten
aber von vielen belächelten 5000 militär
helme die passende allzu leicht ins bild
vielen dank nach berlin geholt
auch das heute im bundestag der zweite
nachtragshaushalt wird 2021 den hat das
parlament gebilligt ursprünglich
vorgesehen war das geld um die kosten
der pandemie zu decken es wurde aber
nicht abgerufen die 60 milliarden euro
sollen in den kommenden jahren für
klimaschutz energiewende und
digitalisierung ausgegeben werden die
union hält diese umschichtung für
verfassungswidrig und will klage
einreichen
und gerade in diesem moment erreicht uns
noch eine wichtige personalie
unionsfraktionschef brinkhaus verzichtet
auf eine erneute kandidatur zugunsten
des neuen parteichefs märz das meldet
die dpa
vor einer woche erschütterte das
gutachten über sexuelle missbrauch im
erzbistum münchen und freising
der ehemalige papst benedikt musste
danach zu geben falsch ausgesagt zu
haben heute nun äußerte sich der
amtierende erzbischof kardinal marx er
entschuldigte sich noch einmal bei
betroffenen und gläubigen und räumte
persönliches fehlverhalten ein aus
münchen barbara lueg
es war wohl ein bitterer gang heute
kardinal marx seine stellungnahme er gab
sich demütig nachdenklich und benannte
eines ganz klar
dass für mich die größte schuld darin
besteht die betroffenen über sehen zwar
das ist unverzeihlich
das jüngste missbrauchs gutachten hatte
das ungeheure leiter betroffenen und ein
systemisches versagen der kirche und
ihrer würdenträger offenbart marx und
seinen vorgängern kardinal wetter und
dem späteren papst benedikt wirft es vor
nicht oder nur unzureichend behandelt zu
haben
ich war und bin ich gleich kritik
hätte ich noch mehr und engagierte
handeln können sicher ja der
reformbewegung wir sind kirche aber ist
das längst nicht genug jetzt geht es
nicht mehr ums reden sondern er muss
jetzt wirklich in seinem bistum und in
der deutschen bischofskonferenz und
weltweit er muss wirklich jetzt wieder
der starke mann sein der sich für
reformen einsetzt da gibt es kein zurück
mehr doch das vertrauen der basis sinkt
die zahl der kirchenaustritte steigt
auch heute ist überhaupt nicht dass
irgendwer wirklich interesse hat an
einem ehrlichen aufarbeitung
doch dieser hat marx heute nun
versprochen aufklärung und
reformbewegung gehe nur zusammen mag
sagt er wolle treibende kraft einer
tiefen veränderung seiner kirche seien
auch deshalb bleibt er im amt vorerst
jedenfalls
anonymität im netz hat vorteile aber
auch tücken etwa wenn unter pseudonym
hass verbreitet wird deswegen verlangt
facebook von seinen mitgliedern dass sie
ihren echten namen verwenden jetzt hat
der bundesgerichtshof aber entschieden
dass das netzwerk auch pseudonyme
zulassen muss allerdings nur für die die
vor mai 2018 mitglied wurden denn danach
trat eben weit die datenschutz grund
verordnung in kraft samuel koch hat mehr
sie wollen anonym im internet ihre
meinung sagen eine frau und ein mann aus
bayern dafür hatten sie geklagt gegen
facebook denn auf der plattform gilt
nutzer müssen als profilnamen ihren
echten vor und nachnamen angeben
facebook erhofft sich davon ein besseres
gesprächsklima doch diese klarnamen
pflicht ist unzulässig so der
bundesgerichtshof
der bundesgerichtshof hat heute
entschieden dass die anbieter sozialer
netzwerke verpflichtet sind den nutzern
die nutzung des netzwerks unter
verwendung eines pseudonyms zu
ermöglichen mit echtem namen für alle
sichtbar zu sein sei unangemessen so die
richter das urteil ist weitreichend es
geht für viele millionen nutzer die
facebook vor mai 2018 beigetreten sind
seitdem hat sich die rechtslage geändert
ob jüngere accounts anders zu bewerten
sind ließen die richter offen zumindest
nutzer aber die schon länger auf
facebook sind haben jetzt rechtsklarheit
der bundesgerichtshof hat heute den
datenschutz im internet gestärkt und
ganz klar gesagt meinungsfreiheit heißt
auch sich anonym äußern zu können das
führt zwar dazu dass einige hass
verbreiten im netz aber anonym bleiben
zu können heißt auch dass man zum
beispiel bei heiklen themen wie
suchtproblematik oder missbrauch nach
hilfe suchen kann ohne dass die menschen
wissen wer man ist surfen unter
fantasienamen auch auf facebook wird das
nun für viele nutzer leichter
ja da hat die lokalmatadoren das einzel
finale erreicht hatte die weltranglisten
erste die hat heute mühelos gegen die
us-amerikanerin madison keys gewonnen
nach 44 jahren könnte wieder eine
australierin die titel holt und sie sagt
letz deutsch
sie spielt zurzeit in einer eigenen liga
ashley partie hat bisher noch keinen
satz und nur ein einziges ihre
aufschlagspiele abgegeben ich bin
einfach froh hier mein bestes tennis zu
spielen und jetzt kann ich sogar nach
dem titel greifen unglaublich
gegen die bisher sehr überzeugend
us-amerikanerin madison keys machte die
25 jährige australierin man muss es so
klar formulieren im halbfinale mit 6 1
und 6 3 kurzen prozess so unantastbar
konzentriert und zugleich locker wie
bharti sich in diesen tagen in melbourne
präsentiert ist sie im finale gegen
daniel collins aus den usa die glasklare
favoriten schon jetzt ist in down under
eine leuchtende ikone und wenn bat die
tatsächlich am samstag gewinnen sollte
hätte sie eine lang ersehnte
australische erfolgsgeschichte
geschrieben
noch acht tage bis zum start der
winterspiele in peking heute wurden
offiziell die drei olympischen dörfer
eröffnet wegen der strengen corona
vorschriften allen die unterkünfte wie
die austragungsorte er
hochsicherheitszone
ohne pomp die offizielle einweihung der
dörfer zu den einrichtungen an den drei
wettkampf hatten gehören auch modernste
jims und science fiction wie diese
hightech kantinen die solche
köstlichkeiten auf tischen die ersten
athleten haben ihre quartiere schon
bezogen und das ioc behauptet
die athleten sind sehr froh hier in
peking die spiele zu zelebrieren das
werden außergewöhnlich sichere spiele
games kroner vorsichtsmaßnahmen mit
helfern in sicherheitskleidung kontakt
soll vermieden werden tägliche tests
gehören zur routine in dem hochhaus
dörfern die hermetisch abgeriegelt sind
wohl weniger zum wohl der athletin
sondern als schutzwall für china
das was an sport ein seltenes schauspiel
erlebt gerade jerusalem es hat geschneit
weiße dächer über der altstadt mit dem
tempelberg zum teil fielen bis zu 20 cm
schnee einige schulen gaben den kindern
schneefrei um das seltene vergnügen zu
genießen einander
nicht ganz so selten der schnee bei uns
mehr dazu gleich von ostern verlieh das
heute journal um viertel vor zehn mit
marietta slomka wir wünschen ihnen noch
einen schönen abend und sind morgen
wieder da um sieben wenn sie mögen auf
wiedersehen
[Musik]
schon genannte und herzlich willkommen
zum wetter ein tief hat uns ja heute
schon erreicht hat regen und schnee in
den höheren lagen gebracht das ganze
verlagert sich nun allmählich
südostwärts das nächste tief steht aber
bereit und kommt dann zum wochenende zu
uns lenkt dann von 9 kühlere luft mit
sehr viel wind zu uns teils orkanartige
böen im flachland sind dann möglich dazu
gleich mehr wir schauen auf die nacht
und da ist es glatt auf den straßen im
südosten regen und schnee wandern weiter
südostwärts sonst lockert es auf an den
küsten herrscht teilweise sturm
temperaturen dazu sinken bis auf minus
vier grad an den alpen und vier grad
plus an der see morgen im tagesverlauf
zieht sich der schnee weiter nach
südosten zurück sonst lockert es auf die
sonne zeigt sich häufiger als in den
tagen zuvor und der wind wird strom aus
nordwestlichen richtungen die
temperaturen dazu erreichen höchstwerte
mit einem grad an den alpen und 8 grad
im westen das wichtigste zum wochenende
ist die nacht von samstag auf sonntag da
kommt dieses sturmtief an und bringt
teilweise sehr viel wind mit und regen
bei temperaturen von vier bis elf grad
damit ein schöner abend